mobilisation des gilet jaune aujourd'hui
des rassemblements qui ont eu lieu
devant les locaux des grands médias à
paris les manifestants qui dénoncent une
fois de plus selon eux le manque de
pluralisme dans la presse et
l'influencent des grands groupes
économiques sur ces médias les médias
télévisés ne font pas leur rôle
on va dire de chercheurs de vérité
d'enquêteurs et ils devraient ils sont
trop acoquiné avec le gouvernement et
manipulé justement par ce gouvernement
et par les lois
je sais pas en fait ils ne se posent pas
de question ne se pose pas de vraies
questions sur le bien-fondé que ce soit
des lois et la cohérence de ce qu'on
leur fait dire chaque jour ça change
ben voila depuis le début mars que ce
soit avec la crise du duc au vide et
même avant enfin voilà avec les lois
retraite
donc nous on a été ridiculisé fait
passer pour des séditieux des factieux
des violents des antisémites ou des
fachos tout a été fait pour nous diviser
et nous ridiculiser face à face à la
population française c'est comme ça que
notre mouvement gilet jaune qui a été un
mouvement pour le bien commun un peu
diminué